[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue vous connaissez la formule quatre
sujets quatre invités et 47 minutes pour
échanger des opinions de préférence
contradictoires nous allons parler
aujourd'hui de l'affrontement très
violent qui oppose charlie hebdo à
mediapart
après l'éditorial du directeur de
charlie rice accusant edwy plenel de
condamnés à mort ou une seconde fois
charlie hebdo nous allons revenir sur
cette affaire balances ton port vous
avez où sont dénoncés des comportements
d'agression sexuelle le dernier viser et
l'ancien directeur de mouvement des
jeunesses socialistes
thierry marchal bec et puis nous
parlerons aussi de déclarations ce matin
de la présidente par intérim de sens
commun qui disait si on veut dénoncer
les ports il faut aussi dénoncer les
porcheries elle faisait allusion à la
pornographie les djihadistes qui
reviennent en france
un reportage de la bbc indique qu'un
certain nombre de djihadiste français
ont réussi à quitter jaca en syrie pour
pouvoir revenir en france avec
l'objectif de commettre des attentats
faut-il une justice d'exception pour ces
délinquants pas comme les autres nous en
parlerons et nous parlerons enfin
d'emmanuel macro qui est avec le
ministre de l'écologie nicolas hulot à
bonn pour la coop 23 cette nouvelle
conférence de l'onu sur le climat
emmanuel macron peut-il sauver peut-être
pas le monde mais en tout cas le climat
nous y reviendrons avec leucate invité
denis tillinac conçoit un soir vous êtes
écrivain journaliste essayiste votre
dernier livre l'âme française est paru
l'année dernière aux éditions albin
michel bonsoir avec si lacroix directeur
délégué de la rédaction de l'express ses
contributeurs de la revue la règle du
jeu
bonsoir guillaume demont jour vous êtes
comporté au figaro magazine
et enfin last but not least renaud
girard le chroniqueur international du
figaro votre dernier livre qu'elle
diplomatie pour la france prendre les
réalités telles qu'elles sont et paru
cette année aux éditions du cerf nous
commençons donc cette émission en
parlant de du débat très violent qui
oppose le directeur de charlie hebdo à
celui de médiapart
dans l'édito de charlie de cette semaine
riis le directeur de ce journal condamne
une phrase edwy plenel en disant ça
n'est plus une opinion c'est un appel au
meurtre je vous propose de revenir sur
cette phrase edwy plenel a prononcé la
semaine dernière mais c'est le coeur du
sujet on la réécoute la lune de charlie
hebdo fait partie d'une campagne plus
générale que l'actuelle direction de
charlie hebdo épouse
monsieur val et d'autres parmi lesquels
tous ceux qui suivent monsieur val une
gauche égaré les gauches qui ne sait
plus où elle est alliée a le droit de
voir une extrême droite identitaire
trouve n'importe quel prétexte non
importe quel calomnie pour en revenir à
leurs obsessions la guerre aux musulmans
la diabolisation de tout ce qui concerne
les flammes et les musulmans restent
dans son éditorial revient sur cette
partie de phrases en dix ans la une de
charlie hebdo celle qui mettait en cause
mediapart donc celle de la semaine
dernière fait partie d'une guerre aux
musulmans
ce n'est plus une opinion c'est un appel
au meurtre cette phrase désigne charlie
hebdo comme un agresseur supposé des
musulmans elle acquitte déjà ce qui nous
tuerons demain denis tillinac est-ce que
ça va trop loin ce débat est-ce que
c'est trop violent
oui je ne connais pas tous les attentes
tous les attendus mais enfin bon j'ai
l'impression qu'on perd un peu le sens
de la mesure
des deux côtés bon il est évident que
plenel à manifester pour les mouvances
islamiques des complaisances
un peu inquiétante fâcheuses et puis qu
il est il essaie de diaboliser tous ceux
qui trouvent que le l'islam contemporain
dans sa version politique radicale
mettait une main et une menace pour à
peu près pour aujourd'hui dire to play
sur toutes les sociétés y compris à
commencer par la société démocratique
bon d'un autre côté les garçons charlie
hebdo on part à le traiter d'assassins
potentiels non plus tout cela est
excessif tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant vision on voit les états
les rangs on voit la violence de ce
débat avec d'autres déclarations que je
propose d'écouter tout de suite ça nous
ira le débat qui reprendra bien sûr
ensuite on va écouter dans l'ordre
laurence rossignol qui est une sénatrice
socialiste ancien ministre de la famille
et manuel valls qui était lui-même pris
à partie par edwy plenel et qui vous
verrai tient des propos extrêmement
virulents voire violent on regarde ces
edwy plenel qui confond les musulmans
les islamistes quand au nom de la
défense des musulmans et il en arrive à
assimiler les allées les critiques la
langue acérée les de charlie hebdo à
l'encontre des islamistes dire que
d'énoncer des islamistes mais non c'est
un gramme adam c'est porter atteinte aux
musulmans c'est une assimilation
préjudiciable à tous les musulmans qui
en france la phrase de 2016 la mienne
reste prémonitoire sur les gauches
irréconciliables wii la wii ce sont des
gens dangereux ce qui prononce ses
phrases qui les écrit parce qu'il y en a
qui les entendent y en a qui lisent
entendent ces phrases je veux qu'ils
reculent
je veux qu'il rende gorge je veux qu'il
soit écarté du débat public non pas par
l'interdiction
c'est pas le sujet les rentes gorge
qu'il perde qu'il perde ce combat et
cette guerre que mon honneur de leur
crédit mais cette guerre d'idées cette
bataille d'idées mais celle-là nous la
menons pour la république et je l'amène
pour les musulmans de france parce que
c'est nous qui les protège on sait pas
monsieur plenel et ses sbires métier la
croix je veux qu'il rende gorge que
manuel valls lui aussi va trop loin
je ne crois pas j'ai échangé d'ailleurs
au moment de cette émission de ce matin
jean jacques bourdin interrogé quelques
sms avec lui pour avoir des précisions
sur cette manuel valls absolument et
c'est je peux vous dire que sa pensée
n'est pas violente sa pensée contrastée
elle est nuancée manuel valls pense que
la distinction fondamentale c'est celle
qui doit exister entre l'islam et lisse
hays l'islamisme entre les musulmans de
france et l'intégrisme religieux
ils n'ont rien à voir avec l'intégrisme
religieux il faut penser la dissociation
des deux choses et ce qu'ils reprochent
en l'occurrence à edwy plenel et à sa
sur réaction aux provocations et
attaques dont il a été victime
c'est d'avoir en quelque sorte noyer
l'islamisme dans l'islam causant un
préjudice immense à nos compatriotes
musulmans qui ne sont pour rien dans le
terrorisme
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose si vous voulez c'est que
si on se place du point de vue de
charlie hebdo il est absolument évident
ciblé que le droit à l'irrévérence le
droit au blasphème n'est absolument pas
la stigmatisation d'une catégorie de la
population ou alors disons les choses
clairement donnons raison à emmanuel
todd et à son lit bell contre la
génération charlie où il prétendait que
si nos compatriotes musulmans étaient
descendus en 6 ainsi faible nombre dans
les rues pour protester contre les
attentats de janvier 2015 c'est parce
qu'il y aurait eu dans ce geste
quasiment unanime des républicains en
france de droite comme de gauche
une forme d'islamophobie l'attend ça
n'est évidemment pas vrai le combat de
charlie hebdo on peut le trouver
stylistiquement déplacés il n'en reste
pas moins que sur le plan éthique
il est assez irréprochable et
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont et louise pennel
sans faire dans la halle et les
surenchères que ça comment dire son auto
défense ou la défense de son pure
players lui occasionne c'est une
évidence ça n'est pas une raison pour
renvoyer dos à dos les partis à mon avis
ce serait ce serait une vision tout à
fait fausses des enjeux enfin last but
not least quand valse dit avec vigueur
certes si l'interview de ce matin était
vigoureuse mais c'est une interview
matricielle quand il dit c'est plutôt
moi c'est enfin en gros c'est plutôt des
républicains comme moi qui protège on
réellement les musulmans de france
il a raison car il ne faut jamais
oublier quand on pense ces problèmes
guillaume la guerre intestine au sein du
monde de l'islam ya une sorte de guet
il entre pour aller vite les démocrates
et les théocrates entre les émules de
massoud
il est ce bear de ben laden si l'on
confond tous ces gens là si on prétend
les défendre mais en les amalgamant les
uns aux autres comme le fait l ouïe
plenel on leur rend un très mauvais
service et je crois valls a raison on
sème les graines d'une discorde
absolument terrible qui vaudra tous les
scénarios les plus noirs que disons un
certain nombre d'écrivains comme
auberton nous font nous font découvrir
en librairie lutter contre l'islamisme
pour protéger les musulmans si c'est moi
tamoil le discours que tenait pas ce
cadre clair dans le figaro magazine
alors dans le dossier que nous allions
radio privée on peut le dire je sais que
pascal bruckner est un de ceux disons
dont la pensée a une certaine influence
sur la ligne idéologique de manuel valls
il n'y a rien de répréhensible si vous
dites le débat est stylistiquement
déplacés moi je crois qu'il est il est
purement stylistique ce débat je lis me
semble en effet des lignes de fracture
idéologique réel mais il renoue avec la
grande tradition pamphlétaire des
journalistes français aujourd'hui on
voit le ton définitif de cet édito de
riise qui dit je ne leur pardonnerai
jamais je ne l'oublierai jamais cette
espèce de deux côtés définitive de on
est on est entre deux personnes qui ont
pris l'habitude d'être écoutés comme des
espèces de boussole du bien oui mais
voilà il nous attendait et c'est le rend
le cuir de couler parce que c'est une
question qui n'a pas été dit à moi qu'on
pense par ailleurs et j'entends ce que
vous dites sur les surenchères
mais dire écrire écrire et dire faire
écrit aussi par les journalistes de son
pure players mediapart qu'il y aurait
dix on dans l'entourage de deva 6 et des
gens qui défendent cette conception de
la république laïque une et indivisible
une tentation identitaire voire
fascisante c'est très grave
c'est très grave car cela impliquerait
qu'à partir du moment où l'on procède à
une critique république à des civils de
l'islamisme on est dans l'islamophobie
merci c'est bien sûr versée c'est très
très grave et j'entends bien au fond de
débat quand même apporter de précisions
alexis islamophobie on a le droit d'être
cristiano fournir en liberté des droits
des christianophobes on a le droit dieu
sait que sa fromagerie aux femmes
on a le droit d'être islamophobe mais tu
sais quoi mais avant il va première
voire et deuxièmement il faut bien
savoir que pour des croyants ce qui
concerne leur froid et là par les plus
précieuses de même il faut savoir le
risque qu'on prend les blessant il faut
en avoir conscience
alors charlie hebdo fait de l'anti fait
de la christianophobie depuis 20 ans ou
30 ans antunez mans parce que les
chrétiens sont grâce au ciel pacifique
on sait les mamans pas le pacifique et
il faut qu'il la je souhaite qu'il leur
est bon mais il se trouve que ils
s'exposent délibérément à une mauvaise
il blesse gravement des gens qui ne sont
pas forcément des intégristes ils sont
passés par là non mais c'est le fond de
l'air parce que est ce que il est bon et
bien de deux blessés dans ce qu'ils ont
plus profond de plus précieux de plus
intime d
des croyants vous vous trouvez que les
bars à trop loin denis tillinac moi
quelque chose j'en pense qu'il est
toujours dommageable de blesser les gens
d'entrer en plus précieux de plus pure
de plus intime donc leur conscience
religieuse il vaut mieux éviter
mais je défends pour autant le droit
d'être chrétien dans fable islamophobe
rationaliste fob laïque au foy's tous
les droites mais je le fais avec mes
temps malheureux parce que je suis
d'accord pas d'accord devant zilina je
trouve qu'il faut effectivement
préserver
la liberté religieuse la liberté de
conscience et respectez vous connais en
tout cas elle reste il faut que l'état
respecte cette liberté cette conscience
individuelle ce qui a le plus précieux
ou cinq hausses au sein de chacun de
nous comme vous dites ça c'est important
mais dieu merci en france la presse
n'est pas la sphère de l'état
alors je pense qu'effectivement des
caricatures comme celle de chalets d'eau
n'ont pas leur place dans les lycées et
dans ce que j'ai à l'état c'est à dire
l'éducation nationale et je serai
ministre l'éducation je n'autoriserai
pas les bibliothèques scolaires à à être
abonné à charlie hebdo
en revanche il ya une liberté de la
presse en france depuis très longtemps
une librairie de la satire
souvenez-vous de daumier et donc voilà
les gens ne sont pas obligés d'acheter
charlie hebdo la une que vous avez
montré qu'ils ont tout d'une assez
amusante alors il est assez il est assez
je trouve ça assez paradoxal que
monsieur plenel qui a changé vraiment
lui-même la ligne du monde qui était un
journal qui avant lui voulait plutôt
garder une certaine impartialité ou ou
en tout cas se disait encore attaché au
vieux modèle d'hubert beuve méry et qui
en a rendu qu'il a fait de lui un jour
d'un extrêmement critique méchant
agressif quand il en était quand il
était le directeur dont il a changé
cette ligne c'était du monde par rapport
à la ligne d'evian son compte et d
hubert beuve méry et des fauves est
c'est assez curieux qui réagissent aussi
mal à une critique non pas si méchante
que ça et qu'il est même assimilé cette
cette affiche rouge à une affiche la
presse collaborationniste alors la
troisième chose que j'ai à dire c'est
que dans cet entretien qu'il a donnée à
europe 1 plein elle accuse valse de
merck sur le mois tout à fait
a fondé et voilà les proches de la
droite de l'extrême droite identitaire
et vous avez dit vous avez dit
identitaire voire fascisant attendait
actuellement il fait actuellement il ya
effectivement un grief venant les
milieux disons proche de mediapart on de
médiapart qui consiste à reprendre la
thèse de mélenchon selon laquelle les
valses east serait lié à une droite qui
l'on doit le voir un extrait droite
voire fascistes alors seulement je veux
dire tout à fait clairement que je
trouve qu'être attaché à son identité
est rattachée à son histoire
attaché à ses valeurs c'est à dire les
valeurs falla à la française qui est
beau mais qu'on va appeler c'est qu'ils
sont les racines des cours latine qui
sont le christianisme judéo
christianisme et qui sont bien sûr les
lumières il n'y a absolument rien de
fascisant et de totalitaire à être à
être attaché à ses racines
et cela même d'ailleurs qui accuse les
conceptions justement identitaires sont
ceux là mêmes qui veulent à tout prix
défendre défendre le droit à l'identité
des communautés c'est tout ils sont tout
à fait en pleine contradiction et donc
donc je ne peux pas effectivement
accepté cette attaque frontale contre
manuel valls paraît il me semble que
face à sète
cette petite critique ce jeu ce gentil
dessins de charlie hebdo contre plenel
j'ai l'impression que edwy plenel a
perdu son sang froid
ou alors il serait agi délibérément je
vous livre les réactions de nos
internautes justin qui nous dit au final
edwy plenel c'est s'abriter de la
liberté d'opinion quand cela arrange ça
c'est vrai et bien si un point
d'interrogation
charlie qui est d'accord avec denis
tillinac pour dire il ne faut pas
provoquer mais nous avons le droit de
penser et orane qui nous dit si
mediapart davis et se montre malhonnête
intellectuellement que va-t-il rester du
journalisme va coûter peut-être que
publication qui sont représentés autour
de cette table biologie non je me disais
juste que je trouvais que
ils sont tous les deux piégé dans l'eure
dans le manichéisme
il ya quelque chose dans ce débat qui
n'est pas complètement fait qu'on qu'il
n'ya pas dia pas de y'a pas d'entre-deux
il n'y a pas de nuances enfin tout est
un peu dans les imprécations il se
trouve que dès lors sa salle eu des
sales et décrédibilise un peu et je ne
trouve pas le complètement porté par non
plus je vois pas des grands penseurs qui
me sens un parent de ce débat et s'est
alors fait pour l'instant il ya quand
même un élément chevaux je vous rejoins
là guillaume sur le mannequin c'est
faible
il ya un élément qui en revanche est
quand même idéologiquement très
intéressant c'est que souvenez-vous
l'époque chirac le plein et l'isthme à
la tête du monde c'était de dénoncer
comme arnaud montebourg
les cadavres dans le placard de la
droite y sont nourris ils sont corrompus
chirac le premier etc aujourd'hui il ya
une sorte de déplacement de l'aja leader
de l'âme de la zone d'accusation il
s'agit avant tout aujourd'hui de faire
la chasse à ce qu'ils appellent les
républicains identitaire est donc pour
eux aujourd'hui le chef des républicains
identitaire dans leur tête c'est manuel
valls et tout ce qu'ils disent on
gravite intellectuellement ou
politiquement autour de lui et donc on a
un nouveau pénale en quelque sorte qui
est devenu un procureur d'autant plus
effréné qu'il a le sentiment aujourd'hui
de faire la police à l'intérieur de la
gauche quand il s'attaquait à la droite
à la limite bon il était sur des vieux
registre un peu caricatural mais qui ne
portait pas vraiment à conséquences et
qui a d'ailleurs permis par parenthèse à
jacques chirac d'être élu haut la main
en 2002 aujourd'hui qu'il s'attaque à
l'intérieur de la gauche
il crée en quelque sorte la situation
d'une sorte de guerre civile des gauches
et évidemment tout là tout le tout
l'excès de la rhétorique anti fasciste
il a appris chez les trotskistes et
qu'il n'a jamais renier est employée
contre des gens de gauche aujourd'hui et
notamment contre manuel valls c'est très
intéressant d'arriver au résultat comme
que congrès que manuel valls qui était
quand même peu plutôt marginalisés
depuis les personnes est en train de
redevenir au coeur du débat il a répondu
non on n'en dira pas moi parce que
parler aujourd'hui
donc on ne va pas parler de manuel valls
encore que on a bien souligné et qu'on a
bien souligné le rôle qu'il avait dans
ce dossier on peut d'ailleurs rappeler
que c'est dans une grande interview au
figaro magazine que manuel valls a
assigné ce retour au premier plan de la
vie politique sur ce sujet je voudrais
que tout part d'un autre thème à présent
la une de libération de ce matin qui
révèle des accusations de huit femmes
qui met tant qu en cause façon très
précise thierry marchal beck alors
peut-être que vous avez oublié qui était
ce monsieur c'était le patron des jeunes
socialistes
il avait l'air bien sous tous rapports
avec son tee shirt et ses cheveux
décoiffés mais apparemment c'était un
agresseur sexuel c'est en tout cas ce
dont il est accusé de façon très très
précises ce qu'on peut préciser aussi
c'est que tirer marché mais qui se
revendiquait régulièrement d'être
féministe comme denis baupin vous
souvenez cet écologiste qui qui mettait
du rouge à lèvres pour dénoncer les
machos voilà ce qu'ont ce qu'on faisait
de mal aux femmes
il se trouve que tous les deux ont été
accusés comme s'il y avait là dans une
espèce de deux d'hypocrisie je voudrais
savoir si vous partagez ce ce point de
vue est ce que il y avait une forme de
tartufferie chez un certain nombre de
ces messieurs qui se disent féministes
ou est-ce qu'il est impossible de
généraliser à partir de deux exemples
denis tillinac accuse ce monsieur ce
jeune monsieur docks de d'agression
sexuelle
l'accusé à retardement l'accusent parce
que ya une espèce de l'emballement
médiatique où tout le monde est en train
de deux voilà vous est ce qu'on appelle
libération n'a pas moi j'appelle
délation et des juifs des résistants et
même des voisins de palier en ans
gravement pâti pendant l'occupation ce
que je déteste ce genre de le cirque si
elle a des problèmes hector leur leader
les incas le dire à ce moment là on
tombe dit même libération que
dignitaires socialistes ç'aurait été
plus ou moins au courant on a dit la
même chose de choses can qu'ils avaient
cole dire avant donc pour moi c'est nul
et non avenu
alors il me semble qu'on peut pas
tolérer
il me semble que denis nous met en garde
sur le plan du principe je suis d'accord
avec lui
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours été dans ses
affaires ça a commencé par strauss kahn
l'autre jour à votre micro cher
guillaume sur weinstein j'ai toujours
été très prudents et là il est légitime
que ces femmes dénonce néanmoins
néanmoins c'est vrai nom mais néanmoins
denis tu as raison de mettre tous les
bémols possible sur ces démarches mais
surtout surtout il va falloir maintenant
que la justice vérifie même en revanche
en revanche mon hypothèse personnelle je
ne connais pas le cas de ce monsieur
mais mon hypothèse personnelle c'est que
effectivement il peut y avoir si vous
voulez des pervers des gens qui sont
vraiment des pervers au sens
psychologique du terme pas forcément au
sens des agissements qui se dissimule
derrière le paravent de cause
apparemment tu insoupçonnable et ça ne
serait pas la première fois
et d'ailleurs le tartuffe de molière est
fondée là dessus ce ne serait ce ne
serait pas psychologiquement on va dire
même si canal éthiquement la première
fois que des personnes qui sont plutôt
sur le modèle de la personnalité
perverse que de la personnalité disons
classiquement névrosé ou obsessionnel se
dissimule derrière le paravent de cause
absolument insoupçonnable et
incritiquable pour mieux commettre leur
méfait l'oppression nous d'accord avec
ça comment vous si je vous dis
maquillage pas cinq ans
est-ce que vous allez nous annoncer j'ai
été violée par alexis lacroix
comment vous allez me prouver je sais
qu'avec ça on fait la une de voici un
tout la belle voix grave et sexy de yun
de bouées pour cette phrase je vais être
combattu c'est un peu de harcèlement je
suis trop loin d'elle soit cargo lie le
calice genoux ses bras nus mais
comprenez vous la parole
il faut toujours revenir aux chiffres
c'est il ya toujours 100 de plus 30% de
plus de plaintes pour agression sexuelle
en un an
c'était un chiffre de la gendarmerie 23
% de plus que la dernière à la même
époque à la police
moi ça me dit que cette fausse
libération la parole est en fait
complètement vaine dans ce courant d'air
médiatique elle ne sert à rien elle est
en plus comme vous le disiez très bien
elle verse faire une délation
complètement enfin qui est vraiment pas
de noble est pas belle équipe a fait
qu'on non plus en revanche là ça veut
dire que dans cette libération il ya
quand même des gens qui m'ont fait la
démarche est pas là à la gendarmerie à
la police pour des projets il se passe
quelque chose donc c'est quelque chose
qui est libérée mais pour en revenir à
l'idée que deux balances ton port c'est
en fait une fausse catharsis ça crée un
espèce de magma de dénonciation et de
est en fait cette affaire des mjs comme
vous disiez très bien moi je le demi ça
en dit long sur la division des jeunes
socialistes la libido des hommes
politiques la libido du pouvoir est un
truc énorme et qu'on a dans lequel on ne
se pose pas assez la question sur ce que
ça actif d'être comme ça comme un tribun
on le voyait sur vos images
un tribun qui harangue la foule est tout
le monde voilà et d'un seul coup ça vous
donne là une espèce de pouvoir énorme
sur les gens et je veux dire quand on
voit les 8es position vous avez vu
libération d'ailleurs c'est un scandale
que libération donne autant de détails
sur sion des circonstances de ces décès
et l on l'accusé mais par exemple il
arrive je vais pas vous raconter mais il
ya une fille qui dit j'ai été obligé de
faire une fellation pour pouvoir
échapper à ca ca sont à ses assauts
c'est quand même très étrange quand même
d'arriver je sais pas si vous vous
présentez là si on fait ça me parait ça
me paraît complètement les jeunes
militantes
dans des bureaux du racing fermé la
porte et me sauter dessus quoi ce set
c'est exactement ça chez renault dont il
est accusé
regardez vous avez évoqué non pas
effectivement de ce carré en son honneur
et sa carrière politique et des foutus
par des rumeurs
quand on a regardé de pouébo l'envoyer
il avoué des tweets pas à longueur de
journée des cochonneries à des collègues
le truc c'était pas non plus monstrueux
et d'ailleurs ça a été calé il assure
une taxe ensuite il a violé personne
jamais ne l'empêchent pas de tout en
empêche qu la rumeur médiatique avec ce
type est moralement foot est le seul
principe qu'il faut pour gagner
lamentable c'est qu' il ne faut pas que
d'autres activités sociales remplace la
justice viol est un crime très grave
droit français dans le crime dans le
droit des airs de tous les pays et donc
c'est ce que vous m'avez décrit est à
une sorte de viande bien s'il se
contente cette info c'est quelque chose
de très grave
maintenant que doyer va dépôt de plainte
est en quête c'est chose de très grave
mais il ne faut pas effectivement ce qui
est un peu dangereux dans nos sociétés
modernes
c'est d'avoir ce lynchage médiatique
c'est à dire que et on a vu ça aussi
vis-à-vis des ministres par exemple vous
souvenez il ya parlant des ministres
accusés d'être des corrompus etc
et puis ensuite donc ils doivent
démissionner c'est arrivé par exemple
vous le dira gérard longuet est arrivé
il a été ensuite il ya eu un non lieu à
massy trop tard contre c'est fini il
fait tout et quand même à pouilly pêche
suprême pour tenter le coup 10
baudis dont l'honneur voilà voilà pour
le chien part à certains journalistes
aujourd'hui alain souchon la leçon sur
la république etc baudis dont l'honneur
et jeté aux chiens et on se rend compte
en suit ensuite que cet homme a été
victime de tels faux témoignages
notamment d'ailleurs du milieu
parce que le milieu joue un rôle
évidemment là dedans et à toulouse le
milieu a voulu plomber 10 et sans avoir
je me suis grand manitou de la gauche
caviar qui m'avait dit à ce moment là à
ce moment là parce que vous savez que
body s'était passé la télévision et ils
sont une chose du niveau d'eau qui issue
est entre la parole d'une [ __ ] et la
parole de ce maire de droite je crois la
[ __ ] et ben non on a pu tellement fait
et la guerre de bosnie c'est cet homme a
été effectivement cassé par un lynchage
médiatique
enfin nous attendons les affaires de
viol sont des affaires très grave
elles doivent être traitées par la
justice papa on va je veux tu que la
justice établisse viol ou pas viol pour
des faits qui remontent à cinq dix ou
quinze ans c'est pas par définition
possible
je voudrais niveau au débat une
déclaration
faites ce matin par madeleine bazin de
jessey présidente par intérim du sens
commun
c'était sur rtl regarder on dénonce les
ports sans dénoncer la porcherie les
liens on ne dénonce pas on dénonce les
effets sans dénoncer les causes donc
c'est pas salutaire les causes derrière
non parce que là c'est la brique j'ai
envie de dire la fabrique du de porc
elle continue à tourner à plein on
s'interroge pas sur la question de la
pornographie notamment les ravages que
ça fait chez les plus jeunes la
conflictuelle isation des relations
garçons filles que ça entraîne la
pornographie c'est un univers où il ya
un rapport hiérarchique dominant-dominé
où les femmes sont considérées comme des
choses on s'interroge pas sur les
publicités sexistes qui utilisent les
femmes pour ratisser les pulsions
consuméristes des hommes voilà il faut
s'interroger sur les causes complètement
avec elle je trouve que c'est tout à
fait c'est ce climat général qui est
propice à ce type de délit d'edf acquis
en fait nourri ce type de comportement
et c'est à ça qu'il faudrait vraiment
réfléchir et j'ai pensé des espèces de
bordures des limites de et à dosage
censure entrer une forme de pudeur fin
de vie quelque chose par exemple
justement moi je trouve ça très
impudique que libération qui est un
grand titre quand même de la presse
nationale puisse décrire des choses
avant même qu ait quoi que ce soit un
procès que ce soit même pas allusif je
trouve que c'est que c'est que c'est une
sorte de ces communes pas lu de face et
un marécage de l'en croire mais sur
internet est ce que vous est ce que vous
seriez favorable les uns les autres à
une forme de censure de la pornographie
c'est bien parce que regarder surfant
sûr c'est que vous voyez un morceau de
cinq appareils il ya des algorithmes qui
serait sans effet l'origine du monde de
courbet parmi les débats on revient
toujours avec le ballon il s'était alors
dit qu'il valait 1 m dans l'histoire de
l'art il ya quand même la nudité
féminine appartient la nullité bascule
mbargane en fille
non pas la pornographie mais donc il
faut faire très attention à cette espèce
de puritanisme dans dans les facebook et
les google ils sortent de terre faut
faire très attention d'ailleurs à une
vie qui n'est qu'une esquisse qui
deviennent insipide si vous voulez je
moi je trouve pas que ce soit
répréhensible par exemple je le dis de
siffler une fille dans la rue
au contraire vous êtes jolie oui voilà
vous êtes jolie wah wah wah ou non mais
il lui dirait quand même répondre à la
question que guillaume nous pose qui est
fondamental plus fondamental je crois et
les façons très courte ce qui sera un
exercice on va essayer ambitieux envoie
contente juste en vous racontant juste
une petite histoire mais elle très
courte
je suis ami enfin depuis de nombreuses
années avec une ancienne qu'on sait
conseiller du président chirac c'est
blandine crier gel qui est une
philosophe et un moment quand elle était
à l'elysée tu t'en souviens unis elle a
voulu réglementer la violence à la
télévision qui est un sujet plus large
mais qui englobe le sujet que vous posez
ça serait la même chose aujourd'hui sur
internet et je ne vous raconte pas le
pourrai vous le dire mieux que moi
le nombre de lobby de producteur de
télévision qui lui sont tombés dessus de
façon très violent de façon très
violente car les vrais empêcheurs de
juguler la violence
ça n'est pas la porcherie qu'évoque
madeleine de gsm en plus ça ne veut rien
dire bien sûr que ça qu'elle faisait
mais la violence dans la relation
gaffiot ici si elle fait référence aux
producteurs faut qu'elle le dise
effectivement ça devient et de certains
milieux de la télévision qui sont
absolument hostile par principe et pour
donner ce parce que ça fait vendre et
par des raisons on fait pour des raisons
fait de boutiques hier à toute
régulation des spectacles de violence en
général à la télévision quand la
rouvraie la terreïs cette extraordinaire
après en convient sans arrêt avec des
armes à feu chez pas une fois sur deux
savent pas c est donc effectivement ça
ne m'étonne pas cette télévision qui
nous vient des états unis puisque la
plupart des films via les et ça ne
m'étonne pas que la société américaine
en plus de leur vente libre des armes
début dangereuse aboutissent assez à ces
drames on en a eu encore un tout
récemment c'était hier je crois en
californie parce qu'effectivement
limitation de ces affaires de
harcèlement tenues un dernier mot sur un
dernier mot le ce blandine barak
rehhagel a été précédée de 20 ans sur le
même thème par ségolène royal
et quand c'est le cas on a voulu lutter
contre la vulgarité la violence à la
télévision elle a été marginalisé à ce
moment là par le ps kedia les pas de
notre culture faut pas oublier ça je
crois que ma de l'année 2002 je sais
tout à fait raison pour la première on
voit arriver adultes des jeunes qui
regardent du porno depuis l'âge de 12
ans j'ai donc dans le psychisme est
complètement décérébrés ça peut amener
le pire le pire c'est le viol le pire
c'est d'ailleurs le pire serait de
toutes les formes de jeu par des voix
morale chantal psychologique
vous parlez des jeux parlons des
jihadistes français si vous le voulez
bien
un reportage de la bbc repris d'ailleurs
dans le figaro de ce matin indique qu'un
certain nombre de djihadiste français
ont réussi à quitter la zone des combats
en syrie et qu'ils ont pour objectif de
revenir en france pour mener des
attaques
la question se pose de la réponse pénale
à apporter à ces à ces djihadistes
rentrer dans leur pays qui est aussi le
nôtre
je vous propose d'écouter ce qu'en pense
eric zemmour ce sujet et l'objet de sa
chronique dans le figaro magazine et et
nous a livré en avant première sa
réflexion là dessus est ce que nous
considérons ces gens là comme des
délinquants normaux à qui on doit
appliquer les règles de droit normal de
d'un état de droit avec les toutes les
toutes les protections que prévoit notre
droit ou est ce que nous considérons que
ce sont des ennemis et qu'on est en
guerre avec eux et qu'on doit leur
appliquer un régime deux belligérants et
donc aucunement de délinquance et c'est
toute la distinction et dupond moretti
et les zones qu'il n'est pas tout seul à
dire ça nous disent plus ils nous disent
en fait toute la stratégie de dèche et
de ces djihadistes c
de nous obliger à sortir de nos règles
de droit et de montrer qu'en fait nous
ne sommes pas des démocraties et d etat
de droit
c'est même ce qu'ils attendraient
exactement je n'y crois pas du tout
renaud girard faut-il une justice
d'exception pour pour les djihadistes
d'abord il faut dire que c'est dommage
quand les ai pas tous tués sur place
donc ma première préconisation
stratégique c'est ce qu'on a des
militaires c'est essayer de les tuer sur
place ceux qui reviennent et qui sont
pris par la police ou qui se donne à la
police sur le territoire français ben je
vais vous dire ça dépend du nombre
si ils sont très nombreux on va pas
pouvoir faire des procès à lamérac
partout donc il va falloir une justice
d'exception
ça dépend en fait ça dépend du nombre de
gens vous avez à juger et toutes les
justices d'exception souvent d'ailleurs
son son sont dus au fait du nombre de du
nombre d'accusés que vous avez que vous
avez à traiter moi personnellement
moralement ça ne me gêne absolument pas
que il ya une justice d'exception contre
des gens d'une façon qui méprise le très
adroit qui méprisent notre démocratie
qui méprisent toutes les valeurs que
nous professons et qui pense d'ailleurs
que ces valeurs sont de la faiblesse
donc en fait vous voyez bien que j'ai
raison de vous combattre vous regardez
bien que vous vous êtes faible puisque
vous vous embarrasser de me faire des
procès qui vont coûter 20 millions
d'euros et puis parce que vous continuez
à lorsque je suis parti me battre avec
des djihadistes de l'état islamique ont
continué à me verser mais mon rsa mes
indemnités
ma sécurité sociale etc et bien non je
suis dans une guerre si effectivement
comme l'a dit le président rowland nous
sommes dans une guerre
eh bien je considère qu'il faut être
impitoyable
alors je te dis que cette sévérité cette
fermeté elle est partagée très largement
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est qu'il ya 3
millions d'abonnés sur le fil twitter du
figaro on les a on les a questionnés
valentin pilati six présidents les
accusés mais du figaro.fr bonjour
valentin vous aurez les réponses elles
sont elles sont assez stricts assez
ferme assez unanimes m
oui d'accord il faut une justice
d'exception pour ce genre alors pas
vraiment non
comme tu dis on a posé la question sur
twitter nous 3 millions d'abonnés afin
de savoir ce que pense donc les
internautes de cette justice d'exception
et les réponses sont claires et nettes
ils sont contre le retour en france car
trop risqué voire même considéré comme
étant un signe de faiblesse vous lisez
renault à l'instant de nombreux
internautes réclament donc au soin la
déchéance de nationalité et
l'interdiction du territoire la
perpétuité
un jugement sur les lieux de leur crime
ou encore de nombreuses reprises la
peine de mort qui revient sur la table
donc on commence avec ce premier tweet
de fauqué ils ont fait un choix ils
doivent assumer il réclame donc la
déchéance de ness il réclame donc en
l'occurrence fauquet la déchéance de
nationalité
l'interdiction de territoire national et
un jugement sur place c'est pareil pour
alain la justice doit être exercée sur
place compte tenu de l'état de guerre
on a mal ou qui renchérit qu'il soit
jugé sur les lieux de leur crime
la perpétuité est suggérée par sébastien
ils doivent être traités comme des
criminels de guerre
intelligence avec l'ennemi 30 ans de
prison à défaut de perpétuité réelle et
donc je vous disais la peine de mort
signalez à de nombreuses reprises
notamment par cet internaute sur twitter
la peine de mort où ils restent là où
ils sont qui va croire ça vous inquiète
ses réactions et pas du tout je
comprends très bien ce besoin de fermeté
d'ailleurs je le partage
parce que je pense qu'une république
démocratique n'a pas de sens si vous
voulez si elle déroule un tapis rouge à
ses ennemis au rétablissement de la
peine
pétale attendait une république je
répète une république démocratique n'a
pas de sens et se renie si elle déroule
un tapis rouge à ses ennemis mortels
donc je ne céderai pas personnellement
au chantage de ce qu'ils nous disent
comme certains avocats justement de ces
personnes qu'il faudrait en quelque
sorte reculer et à baisser tous nos
ponts levis face à leurs réquisitions
pour autant je pense aussi et donc il
faut penser je prends les deux en même
temps que la grandeur des démocraties
c'est précisément jusque dans des
situations exceptionnelles de ne pas
céder à la tentation de l'état
d'exception est donc d'appliquer les
règles de droit valide est normal entre
nous si on fait comme le président de la
république s'y engagent des enquêtes cas
par cas sur ces djihadistes sur leurs
familles sur la descendance
on aura une vision assez précise
notamment via les réseaux sociaux qu'ils
ont tous utilisé aussi par forfanterie
en disant regardez aujourd'hui j'ai fait
si j'ai fait ça à jaca ont été revus
donc ils sont traçables
on aura une vision assez précise de ce
qu'ils ont commis ou de ce qu'ils n'ont
pas commis et à partir de là on pourra
appliquer avec toute la sévérité qui est
que requiert cette situation
exceptionnelle les mesures de l'état de
droit mais je ne suis pas pour jeter par
dessus bord l'état de droit au nom dont
on sait qu'elles allaient surenchère
sécuritaire à la mode aux situations
exceptionnelles et les c'est un
travestissement de notre sentiment
d'impuissance cette juridiction
d'exception ciel si elle était appliquée
parce qu'en fait les intelligents ont
réussi à réchapper
ils sont comme vous le disiez dans la
nature aujourd'hui les courageux sont
morts donc c'est une mascarade ceux qui
sont là qui reviennent on voit que c'est
des femmes des enfants des familles et
on dit le procureur de paris d'ailleurs
disaient qu'ils s'étaient plus des déçus
que des repentis donc en effet ils sont
ils sont encore dans leur idéologie l'on
pense au coeur de paris ça voulait dire
cela tension attention on va pas les
lâcher dans la nature on commence à
retrouver son parapente ils sont déçus
mais mais de quoi parle-t-on parce que
moulins cela dit et je suis sceptique à
ce qu'il dit je suis pas du style à vie
me sens pas chez eux un véritable
renommée de cet engagement
mais en même temps en même temps c'est
une mascarade parce que n'importe va
gérer ces djihadistes a évidemment on va
les mettre dans une juridiction
exception c'est guantanamo enfin céder
c'est toujours ça a produit des
résultats qui sont totalement négatif
qui ne sont pas les bons donc on en fait
on n'a jamais trouvé encore la solution
pour traiter ces personnalités là pour
les rééduquer tous ces centres de
rééducation afin de d d islamisation de
déradicalisation sont servis record donc
en fait on n'a pas encore la solution
mais on est dans cet étau entre deux et
vous avez tout à fait raison de dire que
ce serait un aveu de faiblesse de co2
les soumettre à une juridiction
d'exception moi je suis totalement
contre et en plus je crois profondément
que tout homme peut se re mettre dans
une autre dynamique donc je suis sûr que
la rédemption est possible que tout est
possible donc on les tue et sur place et
radicale mais je pense que concrètement
une durée d'action exception en tout cas
n'est pas du tout à l'ordre du jour elle
n'est pas souhaitable de nutrinautes oui
bon et pas question de renoncer à l'état
de droit bien entendu deuxième axe
important de gagner à l'aj auxerre alors
nous sommes en temps de guerre nous
appartenons à une coalition ce sont des
ennemis et doivent être traités comme
des ennemis fait prisonnier et donc
la justice normal oui on reste dans le
respect de la convention de genève doit
les pouvoirs et si possible en irak ou
en syrie bon c'est pas toujours possible
ce qui demanderait jugé en france je
vois pas comment on peut de techniques
et relationnelles la convention de
genève ne protège pas besoin d'emprunter
ce genre d'irrégularité pour les
insurgés défendent homme de terrain est
accidenté qui doivent être jugés en
france
alors il ya ceux qui viennent pour
délibérément vont commencer attentats
puis à ceux qui demandent à être jugé
parce qu'il ya les femmes et les enfants
enfin il ya des cas d'espèce je crois
qu'il faut qu'il joue qu'il soit jugé
je crois que de toute façon est un titre
réservé à thouars ils doivent être tous
encasernés quelque part il faut
construire des formes de détention
appropriées et puis donc on les traite
comme des ennemis de guerre et on les
juge normalement comme un autre alors en
prenant conscience qu'un guantanamo a eu
des effets pervers mais guantanamo
n'était pas en soi n'a toujours pas été
fermée avec qui le fermera donc
apparemment c'est que c'était pas si
inutile que ça s'entend pilate il
faisait faisait état de nombreux
témoignages d'internautes disant il faut
déchoir de leur nationalité
c'est france est ce que c'est possible
parce que c'est souhaitable oh bien sûr
il faut il faut des choix si c'est
possible si je crois que ça soit la
patrie douala et puis alors évidemment
mais c'est toute la question de savoir
les intelligences ce qui arrive à
revenir en france pas passer en turquie
à prendre un vol de turkish airlines est
arrivé en france et à l'est parce que si
effectivement on pouvait les juger sur
place jeux sur le lieu le crime pourquoi
pas ça serait très bien tout le monde le
soit leur accord ce soir
silva ne pouvait des choix les interdire
de territoire français parce
qu'effectivement l'état français un
devoir de justice bien sûr mais il a un
devoir encore plus important qui est le
devoir de protection de ses citoyens et
de protection de la constitution de
protection de ces lois est donc
effectivement que vous le dis j'ai très
bien avec ci ne pas leur dérouler à
tapis rouge même un tapis de lieder pas
de tapis du tout mais leca qui est posée
dans ce que vous nous dites c'est
évidemment lorsqu'ils sont intelligents
et qu'ils sont parvenus à revenir en
france et qui se font arrêter soit parce
qu'ils se dénoncent eux mêmes ou soit
parce que ils vont aller chercher leur
rsa
il nous reste quelques minutes merci
beaucoup valentin pour parler du la
dernière initiative diplomatique du
président macron plus exactement son
dernier déplacement
c'est à bones est en ce moment même à la
conférence de l'onu dite coop 23 sur le
climat est ce que il est encore temps
d'agir pour le climat est ce que
emmanuel macron est vraiment convaincu
par l'urgence écologique je propose pour
ouvrir le débat d'écouté ce qu'en dit
sébastien lecornu qui est secrétaire
d'état la transition écologique c'est
vrai que c'est le numéro 2 de nicolas
hulot et lui trouve que le président l'a
public va tout à fait faire le travail
vous me direz que c'est pas une surprise
on va l'écouter quand même moi j'ai un
engagement sur le sujet ne soit ce que
parce que la transformation du modèle
français
c'est aussi une transformation du modèle
économique français j'ai passé trois
jours avec lui en guyane où la question
environnementale avec leur paillage
illégale avec un certain nombre de
projets sont vraiment majeurs et j'ai vu
toute l'application qu'il pouvait avoir
sur le sujet il y aune et moi je suis un
vrai écologique frei emmanuel macron ya
deux choses je pense que on l'avait déjà
dit mais je pense qu'il a il a
profondément pas la culture écolo du
tout du tout il a envie de relancer la
croissance et il sait que relancer la
croissance ça passe pas par un effort
écologique ça c'est pas simultanée
il faut commencer par relancer la
machine économique reprendre des points
de croissance et à se partir de ce
moment-là peut-être
cerise sur le gâteau on arrivera à
débrancher un peu de
deux réacteurs nucléaires et tout ça
donc je pense que profondément il est
pragmatique et mon avis son agenda n'est
pas celui qu'on aimerait que les écolos
aimerait certes tout de suite ici et
maintenant j'arrête tout et c'est donc
d'ailleurs nicolas hulot mange son
chapeau avale des couleuvres on a
cinquante expression pour décrire sa
situation lui par contre est un vrai con
vaincu donc je pense que le désirant
garder au gouvernement
macron est obligé d'intégrer cette
urgence et donc il donne des petites
mesurettes des valable mais ce n'est pas
un grand mouvement de fond comme on
pourrait le souhaiter quand on est écolo
à gérard des discours mais pas beaucoup
d'actes je veux c'est très difficile
parce que en fait il faut d'abord avoir
l'accord des pays qui polluent le plus
là la france polluent peu elle pollue
plus d'ailleurs parce que elle a
beaucoup d'électricité nucléaire donc
elle peut lui beaucoup moins que
l'allemagne qui elle est restée au
charbon le savons c'est ce qui est le
plus polluant mais la grande position
mondiale
elle vient pas de la france elle vient
de la chine
de là les états unis et qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
le poids de la petite france de mâcon
pour faire changer la stratégie
industrielle de l'inde ou de la chine
ce poids est limité donc ce serait même
ridicule qui pense qu'il va pouvoir
changer la stratégie sion en revanche ce
qui ce qui ce qui se passe depuis bon et
donc il ya eu l'état français a organisé
et fort bien cette comme 21 il faut
rendre hommage sur ce point pas sur le
reste
alors enfin bus communiste d'affaires
étrangers donc et il ya en ce moment une
prise de conscience chinoise très
importante et vous avez vu dire que
partout il remplace les scooters à
essence par des scooters électriques en
chiffon beaucoup en chine
ils font beaucoup aidés à nous sommes
nous sommes très en retard en france
c'est dommage nous sommes très en retard
nous avons inventé la voiture
moteur à explosion est assez plus tard
nous avons comparé raté nous sommes un
des derniers dans des campagnes et
développé à développer la voiture
électrique nous devrions rattraper
j'espère j'espère ce retard mais je ne
pense pas que qu'emmanuel mâcon puisse
faire beaucoup plus qu'il ne fait
aujourd'hui parce qu'il n'a pas à pas
les leviers il n'a pas les leviers et la
france a fait ce qu'elle devait faire
alors libre aux chinois je pense qu'ils
en prennent conscience de savoir est ce
qu ils veulent vivre et mourir beaucoup
plus jeunes parce qu'ils vous ont besoin
de nuage de pollution est ce qu'ils
veulent vraiment changer les choses ou
pas la même chose pour l'inde
alexis lacroix alors je suis d'accord
sur les limites de dison du pouvoir de
macron est aussi son enfermement
en tout cas tout jusqu'à nouvel ordre
dans un paradigme techniciste et de
croissance de relance de la croissance
c'est la même chose d'ailleurs c'est une
idée que plus on accélère sur le
champignon des dépenses énergétiques
plus on va libérer la croissance et donc
relancer l'entreprise et que ferry gants
et donc sert accroître le bien de
l'économie pour autant n'oubliez jamais
que emmanuel macron même quand il est
empêché même quand il est piégé
une autre dimension de lui même qui est
souvent d'ailleurs la dimension
intellectuelle et laborde est sortie de
crise et donc je pense que on peut quand
même faire crédit à ce président
philosophe d'avoir pris pleinement la
mesure en ce sens d'ailleurs comme hulot
qu'il protège du fait que notre modèle
de civilisation notre d'un modèle de
dépense énergétique va devoir que nous
voulions ou pas être remis à plat de
fond en comble je crois que macron il
faut pas les faire l'injure de penser
qu'il ne sait pas que notre modèle n'est
pas ce style est belle comme on dit en
anglais voilà je pense qu'il le sait
parfaitement
et donc il se donne le temps dont il se
donne le temps guillaume le disais c'est
très juste il se donne le temps mais je
crois qu'au cours des quatre ans qu'il
reste à la tête de peut-être même plus
s'il est réélu il va il va faire les
choses et c'est pour ça bien sûr qu'il
ne veut pas sacrifier la brebis
l'eau sur l'autel des vengeurs de droite
et de gauche qui demandent sa tête cette
semaine qui a eu une déclaration
foncièrement c'est quand même un
technocrate productiviste enfants de
l'ena c'est ce que j'ai dit lâche accusé
armée avec les écolos parce que la même
joie pour compléter sa majorité c'est
celui-là c'est l'os et le rocher et
télévisuelle je suis pas sûr que il veut
que je crois je suis pas d'accord avec
vous il veut essentiellement des points
de croissance pour me lancer la machine
parce que oui mais ces trois points
trois de plus et un point d'écart
j'aimais donné ses pointes traoré ans
peuvent précisément passé par les
énergies vers cette révolution à 6,6
voulons faire si vous remplacez tout
depuis deux semaines par des films
chinois d un double et des amériques de
sous-estimera ne sous-estimez pas ma
carrière que je ne suis pas sûr
thuriféraires m surtout m 2 par rapport
à mai mais bien non c'est pas son
préféré nous le souhaite mais je ne
sous-estimé pas et ne sous-estimé pas
aussi la trace mémorielle ou mesic qui
lie à chez lui du discours auquel tu as
dû contribuer denis de chirac à
johannesbourg en 2005 quand il dit notre
2003 quand il dit notre maison brûle
voilà et je pense que macron veut aussi
parce que macron ils pensent ils pensent
déjà dans l'éternité une partie son
cerveau pense dans l'état des il veut
aussi laisser une trace sur le plan de
la défense de l'environnement a
découvert ce dernier ce dossier vous
avez vu cette semaine qui a une
déclaration de plusieurs milliers de
scientifiques disant attention la maison
brûle le il sera bientôt trop tard et
dans les mesures qu il
appellent de leurs voeux notamment pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique ils disent il faudrait
réduire encore le taux de fécondité une
sorte de retour de malthus et écouter ce
qu'en dit pierre rabhi qui est un
pionnier de ce qu'on appelle
l'agroécologie il était interviewé hier
par marie laëtitia bonavita dans
conversations qui est une autre émission
de figaro live et lui il est tout à fait
opposés à cette volonté de réduire la
fécondité mondial
regardez je n'approuve pas cela parce
que quand on prend l'ensemble de
l'humanité
il ya vraiment une humanité qui est
souffrance sur cette terre qu'il n'a
même pas accès à de l'eau potable la
nourriture etc
c'est bien joli nous bien nourri et ses
atouts pour faire des grandes
proclamations 30 à 40% de la créativité
humaine dans les pays dits riches s'ils
superflu il ya qu'à visiter les
décharges publiques et le marché pour se
rendre compte que nous produisons
énormément de choses inutiles à ce point
en occident avant de vouloir que les
autres moines enfants non plus d'accord
que j'ai mais arrivé dans une vie
antérieure de publier pierre rabhi je
connais bien oui je crois que je crois
qu'il a raison
pour autant si on pouvait contrôler un
peu plus les naissances 20 et pays où la
pression démographique d'alors détruit
fait plus que compenser la croissance
c'est bien pour tout le monde je pense
je pense à l'afrique subsaharienne voilà
parce qu en afrique du nord il ya
maintenant effectivement et des taux de
fécondité tout à fait comparable qui se
rapproche des des taux européens
je pense que très très clairement
l'allemagne a pas assez d'enfants
l'allemagne pour là pour la retour des
générations à douala le renouvellement
démographique mais en revanche en
afrique et on voit ça il y à il ya des
villes où il ya très clairement une
explosion démographique non contrôlée si
vous allez à l'ego si vous allez au
niger si vous allez au kenya à nairobi
s'est senti floué dans la hutte
hélas hélas elle est là c'est pas
gérable en termes de quoi en terme
d'hôpitaux en terme d'écoles parce que
ses enfants ont foulé et donc
effectivement un peu
de contrôle de la natalité je ne veux
pas une politique mondiale à une
politique est là l'enfant unique comme
en chine il ya un problème maintenant de
vieillissement en chine mais en revanche
oui il faut le dire très clairement en
afrique subsaharienne
il ya un vrai problème de non contrôle
de la démographie
le temps est venu de rendre l'antenne je
termine en vous citant 7
ce conseil donné par williams à emmanuel
macron s'il souhaite sauver le climat
il faut s'entendre avec tout le monde
dont les états unis
merci à tous les quatre et bonsoir n'a
pas tort
[Musique]